un show qui mêle humour et danse jeremy
jones et le coup de coeur de la royale
factory j'aimerais bien être avant ça
professionnelle parce que c'est vrai oh
non moi qui rêvais d'avoir un michel
platini à la maison mais voilà avec
michel pietragalla tu veux faire de la
danse avec une raquette
l'humour c'est le fil rouge des
programmations de la salle versaillaise
des artistes reconnus comme manu payet
jérémy ferrari et guillaume backs la
royale factory elle donnait sa scène à
tous on laisse toujours la place aux
humoristes soit en devenir mais toujours
professionnel et on va les voir deux
trois fois avant de les programmer et on
les suit dont les reprogramme j'appelle
ça mais grand chevalier mois il arrive
avec un thème ça peut parler
d'homosexualité ça peut parler de danse
des parcours voilà particulier des uns
et des autres qui m'intéresse et
généralement ça intéresse au public
parce qu'ils viennent fidèles ici à la
royale sauver votre couple démarrer une
série télé une bonne série télé
américaine bien foutu avec plein
d'épisodes c'est une femme elle ne
partira pas avant la fin de la saison
la royale factory laisse aussi une place
à la jeunesse des rendez-vous
principalement pendant les vacances pour
partir à la recherche d'un professeur
pour découvrir les contes de perrault ou
découvrir un génie l'enfance de léonard
de vinci on est très content c'est les
500 ans de léonard de vinci est vraiment
ce spectacle c'est complètement adapté
c'est pour les plus jeunes pour les plus
grands que c'est un super moment
une quarantaine de dates est déjà
programmée la salle peut accueillir
entre 160 et 180 4 spectateurs